en el vídeo anterior vimos la
alquilación de freedom prods en este
vídeo veremos la afiliación que es muy
parecida a la alquilación empezamos con
benceno y añadimos cloruro de asilo esta
parte corresponde al grupo asilo y
también usaremos cloruro de aluminio
como nuestro catalizador
como podemos ver el grupo así lo
sustituye a un protón del anillo
aromático es una sustitución electro
física aromática el mecanismo para una
aislación es muy parecido al de la
alquilación aunque hay una diferencia
muy importante que veremos en un momento
empiezan de la misma manera el cloruro
de aluminio funciona como un ácido de
louis aceptará un par de electrones
entonces el cloro donará un par de
electrones y el aluminio los aceptará
dibujemos el resultado de esta reacción
ácido base aquí tenemos a nuestro grupo
carbón hilo y luego tenemos el cloro
unido a nuestro aluminio que a su vez
está unido a otros tres claros no
dibujar esos pares de electrones libres
para
ahorrar tiempo el aluminio tiene una
carga formal negativa y este cloro tiene
una carga formal positiva resaltemos a
los electrones estos electrones en rosa
son los que formaron un enlace entre el
cloro y el aluminio para encontrar a
nuestro electro filo necesitamos pensar
en que estos electrones se van con el
cloro entonces le quitamos un enlace a
este carbono ahora nos queda un grupo
carbón hilo con una carga formal
positiva este carbono sigue unido al
oxígeno y al grupo r
hemos creado un camión de asilo que es
nuestro electro filo para la sustitución
electro física aromática este camión es
estabilizado por resonancia así que
podemos tomar este par de electrones en
el oxígeno y moverlos hacia aquí esta es
una diferencia entre la oscilación y la
alquilación en la reacción de
alquilación formamos un kart vocaciòn
que necesitaba de un real regla para ser
más estable lo cual dificultó el control
de los productos que obteníamos en
cambio con la asimilación no hay
arreglos debido a la estabilidad por
resonancia de nuestro camión de asilo y
bueno también formamos un complejo por
acá ahora el aluminio está unido a 4
cloro
y este cloro ahora tiene tres pares de
electrones libres a su alrededor
resaltemos estos electrones en color
naranja que terminaron quedándose con el
cloro aún tenemos una carga forma
negativa en este aluminio el catalizador
ha generado a nuestro electro filo y
ahora podemos mostrar a nuestro electro
filo el camión de asilo reaccionando con
el benceno para el mecanismo podemos
usar cualquiera de estas estructuras de
resonancia usemos la estructura de la
derecha tenemos una carga formal
positiva en el carbono y por acá tenemos
un grupo r
esta es nuestra situación núcleo filo
electro filo cargas positivas atraen a
las cargas negativas así que estos
electrones bi funcionarán como núcleo
filo y atacarán al electro filo
agregándose a nuestro benceno lo pondré
en el carbono de arriba que también
tiene un hidrógeno entonces en este
carbono se forma un enlace con el carbón
y lo aquí tenemos algunos electrones
libres y por acá tenemos al grupo r
sigamos a los electrones estos
electrones en rosa funcionaron como
núcleo filo y formaron este enlace entre
el carbono y el carbón y lo como le
quitamos un enlace a este carbono
entonces aquí tenemos la carga formal
positiva y esta es una de las posibles
estructuras de resonancia podríamos
dibujar las demás pero no lo haremos
para ahorrar tiempo en los vídeos
anteriores pueden ver cómo dibujar
estructuras de resonancia por ahora
digamos que esta estructura representa a
nuestro complejo sigma y claro para
finalizar con la reacción
necesitamos des protón ar el complejo
sigma y regenerar el anillo aromático
así que estos electrones tomarán a este
protón dejando estos electrones
que se moverán para reformar el anillo
aromático quitando la carga formal
positiva
reformamos nuestro anillo aromático y
ahora tenemos el grupo asilo unido al
anillo sigamos a los electrones estos
electrones en morado se movieron hacia
acá que más se ha formado estos
electrones en rojo formaron un enlace
con el protón así que también formamos
hcl y claro que generamos a nuestro
catalizador a el cl 3
esta es la afiliación de freedom craft
veamos una situación en la que podamos
usar la asimilación de freedom craft en
lugar de la alquilación digamos que
nuestro objetivo es obtener útil benceno
a partir de benceno
dibujar el butil benceno por aquí
tenemos un grupo aquí lo de 4 carbonos
saliendo del anillo
en el vídeo anterior vimos que con la
alquilación de free del craft obteníamos
el butil benceno pero debido al rea
regla del carbó catión resultó ser el
producto en menor cantidad pero si
queremos que se forme en mayor cantidad
podemos usar la afiliación de freedom
craft entonces para obtener el útil
benceno usando una aislación necesitamos
poner en el benceno un grupo así lo que
tenga el mismo número de carbonos en
este caso un grupo asilo de 4 carbonos
ahí está y este es el carbono 1 2 3 y 4
también necesitamos añadir un
catalizador cloruro de aluminio como
catalizador
entonces dibujemos el anillo
y por aquí está unido directamente al
carbón hilo
en total debemos tener 4 carbonos este
es 1 2 3 y 4 para formar el compuesto
que queremos es decir el útil benceno
necesitamos deshacernos del carbón y lo
una reacción que se ha utilizado para
eso es la reacción de clemens que
involucra a una amalgama de zinc con
mercurio y una fuente de protones como
hcl la amalgama de zinc reduce el carbón
hilo a un grupo al kilo y por eso la
reducción de clemens en es tan útil en
síntesis esta es una forma en la que
pueden obtener su molécula debut el
benceno en mayor cantidad
usando una aislación que es un poco más
confiable que la alquilación